how can we get people to do more good to
go to the polls give to charity conserve
resources or even to do something as
simple as washing their mugs at work so
that the sink isn't always full of dirty
dishes when I first started working on
this problem I collaborated with a power
company to recruit customers for a
program that prevents blackouts by
reducing energy demand during Peaks the
program is based on a tried and true
technology it's won the Obama
administration even called the
cornerstone to modernizing America's
electrical grid but like so many great
technological solutions it has a key
weakness people people need to sign up
to try to get people to sign up the
power company sent them a nice letter
told them about all the program's
benefits and it asked them to call into
a hotline if they were interested those
letters went out but the phones they
were silent so when we got involved
we've suggested one small change instead
of that hotline we suggested that they
call that they use sign-up sheets that
they'd post near the mailboxes in
people's buildings this tripled
participation why well we all know
people care deeply about what others
think of them that we try to be seen as
generous and kind and we try to avoid
being seen as selfish or a mooch whether
we're aware of it or not this is a big
part of why people do good and so small
changes that give people more credit for
doing good
those changes can make a really big
difference small change is like
switching from a hotline where nobody
will ever find out about your good deed
to a sign-up sheet or anyone who walks
by can see your name in our
collaborations with governments
nonprofits companies when we're trying
to get people to do more good we harness
the power of reputations
and we have a simple checklist for this
and in fact you already know the first
item on that checklist it's to increase
observability to make sure people find
out about good deeds now wait a minute
I know some of you are probably thinking
there's no way people here thought oh
well now that I'm getting credit for my
good deed now it's totally worth it
you're right usually people don't rather
when they're making decisions in private
they worry about their own problems
about what to put on the table for
dinner or how to pay their bills on time
but when we make their decision more
observable they start to attend more to
the opportunity to do good in other
words what's so powerful about our
approach is that it can turn on people's
existing desire to do good in this case
to help to prevent a blackout back to
observability I want to give you another
example this one is from a collaboration
with a nonprofit that gets out the vote
and it does this by sending hundreds of
thousands of letters every election in
order to remind people and try to
motivate them to go to the polls we
suggested adding the following sentence
someone may call you to find out about
your experience at the polls this
sentence makes it feel more observable
when you go to the polls and it
increased the effect of the letter by 50
percent making the letter more effective
reduced the cost of getting an
additional vote from 70 dollars down to
about $40 observability has been used to
do things like get people to donate
blood more frequently by listing the
names of donors on local newsletters or
to pay their taxes on time by listing
the names of delinquents on a public
website what about this example Toyota
got hundreds of thousands of people to
buy a more fuel-efficient car by making
the Prius so unique
that their good deed was observable from
a mile away
all right so their ability is great but
we all know we've all seen people walk
by an opportunity to do good they'll see
somebody asking for money on the
sidewalk and they'll pull out their
phones and look really busy or they'll
go to the museum and they'll waltz right
on by the donation box imagine it's the
holiday season and you're going to the
supermarket and there's the Salvation
Army volunteer and he's ringing his Bell
a few years ago researchers at San Diego
teamed up with a local chapter from the
Salvation Army to try to find ways to
increase donations what they found was
kind of funny when the volunteers stood
in front of just one door people would
avoid giving by going out the other door
why well because they can always claim
oh I didn't see the volunteer or I
wanted to get something from over there
that's where my car is in other words
there's lots of excuses and that brings
us to the second item on our checklist
to eliminate excuses in the case of the
Salvation Army eliminating excuses just
means standing in front of both doors
and sure enough when they did this
donations rose but that's when things
got kind of funny even funnier The
Salvation the researchers were out in
the parking lot and they were counting
people as they came in and out of the
store and they noticed that when the
volunteers stood in front of both doors
people stopped coming out of the store
at all
obviously they were surprised by this so
they decided to look into it further and
that's when they found that there was
actually a third smaller utility door
usually used to take out the recycling
and now people were going out that door
in order to avoid the volunteers this
teaches us an important lesson though
when we're trying to eliminate excuses
we need to be very thorough because
people are really creative in making
them all right I want to switch this
setting where excuses can have deadly
consequences what if I told you that the
world's deadliest infectious disease has
a cure in fact that it's had one for 70
years a good one one that works almost
every time it's incredible but it's true
the diseases tuberculosis and infects
some ten million people a year and it
kills almost 2 million of them like The
Blackout Prevention Program we've got
the solution the problem is people
people need to take their medication so
that they are cured and so that they
don't get other people sick for a few
years now we've been collaborating with
a mobile health startup called ki Kela
to support TB patients as they undergo
treatment now you have to understand TB
treatment it's really tough
we're talking about taking a really
strong antibiotic every single day for
six months or more that antibiotic is so
strong that it will make you feel sick
it will make you feel nauseous and dizzy
it'll make your pee turn funny colors
it's also a problem because you have to
go back to the clinic about every week
in order to get more pills and in
sub-saharan Africa or other places where
TB is common now you're talking about
going someplace pretty far taking you
know tough and slow public transport
maybe the clinic is inefficient so now
you're talking about taking a half day
off of work every week from a job you
desperately can't afford to lose it's
even worse when you consider the fact
that there's a terrible stigma and you
desperately don't want people to find
out that you have the disease
some of the toughest stories we hear are
actually from women
who in these places where domestic
violence can be kind of common they tell
us that they have to hide it from their
husbands that they're coming to the
clinic so it's no surprise that people
don't complete treatment can our
approach really help them can we really
get them to stick it out yeah every day
we text patients to remind them to take
their medication but if we stopped there
there'd be lots of excuses I didn't see
the text or you know I saw the text but
then I totally forgot put the phone down
and I just forgot about it or I let the
phone out to my mom
we have to eliminate these excuses and
we do that by asking patients to log in
and verify that they've taken their
medication they don't log in we text
them again they don't log in we texted
me again if after three times they still
haven't verified we notify a team of
supporters and that team will call and
text them to try to get them back on the
wagon no excuses
our approach which admittedly uses all
sorts of behavioral techniques including
as you probably noticed observability it
was very effective patients without
access to our platform were three times
more likely not to complete treatment
all right you've increased observability
you've eliminated excuses but there's
still a third thing you need to be aware
of if you've been to Washington DC or
Japan or London you know that Metro
riders there will be very careful to
stand on the right-hand side of the
escalator so that people can go by on
the left but unfortunately not
everywhere it's at the norm and there's
plenty of places where you can just
stand up both sides and block the
escalator obviously it's better for
others when we stand on the right and
let them go by but we're only expected
to do that some places this is a general
phenomenon
sometimes we're expected to do good and
sometimes not and it means that people
are really sensitive to queues that
they're expected to do good in a
particular situation which brings us to
the third
and final item on our checklist to
communicate expectations to tell people
do the good deed right now here's a
simple way to communicate expectations
simply tell them hey everybody else is
doing the good deed the company o power
sends people in their electricity bill a
small insert that compares their energy
consumption with that of people with
similarly sized homes and when people
find out that their neighbors are using
less electricity they start to consume
less that same approach it's been used
to get people to vote or give to charity
or even reuse their towels and hotels
what about this one here's another way
to communicate expectations simply do it
by saying do the good deed just at the
right time what about this one this
sticker reframes the kind of mundane
task of turning off the lights and it
turns it instead into an environmental
contribution the bottom line is lots of
different ways to do this lots of ways
to communicate expectations just don't
forget to do it and that's it that's our
checklist many of you are working on
problems with important social
consequences and sometimes you might
need to motivate people to do more good
the tools you learned today can help you
with this and these tools they don't
require that you raise additional funds
or that you develop any more fancy
technologies they just require
harnessing reputations but increasing
observability eliminating excuses and
communicating expectations thank you